[Music]
at any moment of any day the odds are
that someone around the world is having
an orgasm we don't really like to talk
about them but they're an integral part
of our lives
billion-dollar industries have been
built around them people have become
addicted to them and scientists have
studied them for eons while there's
still a level of mystery surrounding
them some experts believe that orgasms
were designed to keep humans reproducing
so what would happen if we stopped
having them which people want to have
sex anymore how could our populations
survive this is what if and here's what
would happen if orgasms didn't exist
without orgasms sex would become a
practical act like working out and just
like working out people might quickly
become bored with it which could cause a
global decline in birth rates but that's
just the beginning
without orgasms we'd be less healthy our
education system would change and our
environment would get a much-needed
boost how can this small physical
reaction have so much control over our
world if none of us were able to
experience orgasms do we really know the
extent of what we'd be missing well
during orgasm your brain shifts most of
its resources to achieve one goal
pleasure one sector of the brain
produces oxytocin a hormone that helps
coordinate arousal another sector digs
deep to bring together all your touch
sensors sexual fantasies and memories
other parts of the brain provide a
handful of feel-good hormones and neuro
chemicals most notably dopamine
mix that all together and boom got
something so good that it's been
compared to trying heroin for the first
time and just like heroin it can leave
to plenty of bad decisions not only do
orgasms feel good but they're actually
good for us too they can act as
painkillers they can reduce menstrual
cramps improve circulation fight aging
boost your immune system and even help
you live longer over a ten-year study
men who had two or more orgasms per week
had a 50% lower mortality risk than
those who experienced fewer happy
endings similar results were found with
women but if orgasms didn't exist it
wouldn't only be these individual
benefits that we'd be missing out on our
society as a whole would be impacted too
some couples would keep procreating
because it's what the human body is
programmed to do but with no pleasure
involved in the process the birthrate
would take a significant dive and if you
were trying to make babies chances are
that sex would become kind of boring who
wants to run a race where you could
never make it to the finish line
with less time daydreaming and
fantasizing about sex teens would
probably do better in school the
dynamics of dating and relationships
would completely change and things like
one-night stands would cease to exist
with each new post orgasm generation
life on the planet would look
increasingly different economies would
shift with fewer children housing
markets would be affected as demand
declines and schools would suffer as
enrollment numbers would drop with the
decreasing population it wouldn't all be
terrible news though with a decrease in
population growth we might see some
benefits for the planet since there
would be fewer people polluting it and
depleting its resources life on planet
Earth might feel a little more focused
perhaps even a little boring maybe one
day we'd grow so bored with sex that all
of our procreation would come through
artificial insemination but that's a
topic for another what is
[Music]